apple ceo tim cook this morning at the
deal book conference dropping absolute
bombs he was asked by andrew ross sorkin
hey tim do you own any bitcoin ethereum
other cryptocurrencies and here is
exactly what tim had to say do you own
crypto in any bitcoin or ethereum would
you play around with this i i do yeah i
think it's reasonable to own it as a as
a part of a diversified portfolio and
i'm not giving anybody uh investment
advice by the way
when when did you get interested in it
i've been interested in it for a while
and uh i've you know been researching it
and and and so forth and so uh i think
it's interesting so when you start to
see the leader of one of the largest
technology companies in the world saying
wait a second i do own this stuff right
and he was a little unclear we don't
know if he owns just bitcoin just
ethereum bitcoin and ethereum other
things but he owns cryptocurrencies in
general and we also don't know exactly
when he bought it we don't know how big
of a portion it is in his portfolio but
he made it seem like duh of course i do
and nobody should be surprised by this
we are talking about a technologist
somebody who literally his job is to
figure out what the most uh latest
technology trends are to figure out what
consumer behaviors are to understand
everything from hardware to software to
payments and everything in between that
is his job so of course he has taken
time to learn about this of course he's
intellectually curious about it and of
course if you understand how to learn it
is by participating he owns some of it
now it would not surprise me to see that
tim cook would be first to kind of be
orange-pilled or to start to use some of
these technologies you first put it on
your own balance sheet you start to use
some of the different products and
services in the industry and then
eventually you start around the office
saying well you know what i was using
this thing it's pretty interesting i
wonder what it would look like if we
were to incorporate some of these
technologies into our products or our
services and so is there a day in the
future where we see apple go ahead and
allow for bitcoin or other
cryptocurrency payments absolutely in my
opinion are there is there a day where
they start to integrate with things like
web 3 or some of the other products and
technologies that people are building
absolutely because ultimately if you go
back to what we've been saying now for a
while crypto is not going to be a
separate industry
instead what you are going to get is you
are going to get crypto to infiltrate
all of the existing assets in all of the
existing industries you are going to
have all of them upgrade their rails all
of them will upgrade their technologies
very similar to a bookstore that used to
just be in the analog physical world it
eventually went online well eventually
that bookstore continued to upgrade its
technologies we didn't think about an
internet bookstore after 10 or 15 years
of the internet of course every
bookstore has an online store the same
thing is going to happen in crypto
however you want to define that whether
you define it by one asset or many
assets these technologies are going to
be pervasive across society and so to
see the leader of one of the most
important most successful technology
companies saying that he owns the
technologies that he owns the assets
shouldn't be a surprise to anyone but i
think the part that we are now watching
is that people are comfortable talking
about it so there's likely that they've
actually owned the technologies for a
while is that they've owned them for
some time they've been intellectually
interested in as you just said but you
couldn't talk about it you might have
come off as crazy or insane or you lost
your mind but now all of a sudden it's
cool to talk about it of course you can
talk about it the career risk has been
removed and so whether it's tim cook
here or somebody else in a position of
power or influence whether they're in
the finance industry the technology
industry or somewhere else they now are
allowed to talk about this technology in
a way that it is
it is expected it is not a surprise to
anyone that they own it and i think that
is to me the biggest takeaway is that
now tim cook is comfortable saying that
he owns this technology and also when he
goes and he does a interview like this
he's asked about it if you go back five
years no one would have asked him about
it and also he would have been
comfortable talking about it but now we
have the questions being asked and we
have him saying it and i think that
you're only going to see this become
more and more part of the mainstream
narrative which means that more and more
people will become educated they'll
become familiarized and we will continue
to see user adoption across the industry
of all sorts of different technologies
and products and services and so tim
cook's in the game apple eventually will
get in the game as well along with every
other major technology company john were
you surprised when you saw that tim cook
owned cryptocurrencies and was so
comfortable talking about it publicly
not really right he's been in the
technology space for pretty much his
entire life um it surprised me that this
hasn't come out before he was pretty
open about it when asked about it so i'm
surprised that no one's ever actually
directly asked him in a public forum
about it um and him actually given an
answer but
i'm curious to see what apple does with
it in the future so he did mention that
apple doesn't hold any bitcoin or
anything like that because people don't
want to invest in apple and have like
that exposure to bitcoin that's not why
they're coming to invest in apple so
we'll see where it goes but does apple
accept this do they invest in companies
that are around this do they start using
the technology within their products or
services um that's where i am kind of
keeping my eye on yeah and i think
that's an important point because at the
end of the day apple's a two and a half
trillion dollar market cap company it's
one of the biggest technology companies
in the world and he's the ceo of it so i
don't think it's surprising to anyone uh
that he's experimenting or owns at least
some of kind of one of the most
disruptive technologies we've seen in
our lifetime so that's not surprising at
all i think the part that is interesting
and people should care much more about
is what apple does right as a company so
uh the follow-up question i believe with
that was like hey are you guys going to
accept payments are you going to hold
bitcoin on your balance sheet and to
john's point he said hey look we don't
want to hold it on our balance sheet not
because i don't believe in it i invested
in it
personally so there's obvious obviously
some kind of personal belief in in the
asset but we don't want to hold it
because our customers aren't buying
apple stock uh to have exposure to
bitcoin and i thought one of the
interesting things that michael saylor
said yesterday was a lot of people when
they think about what michael sailor has
done with microstrategy uh there's a
common complaint saying hey look i don't
want i didn't want to become a levered
bitcoin etf right when i bought
microstrategy stock but what most people
don't know and he talked about yesterday
was that they offered to buy back shares
at a premium if you held microstrategy
stock right so he's before they bought
it before they bought it yeah so he said
this is what we're planning to do if you
don't do not want exposure to bitcoin if
you don't want to be part of this if you
don't believe in that future direction
we'll buy your shares back from you at a
premium to its current price which is
like the most baller move of all time
right because it's like hey look we have
shareholders we care about you we want
you know it's changing it's a large set
of people but even retail small guys
that have one share of our stock we care
about you right and we want you to know
uh that this is the direction we're
going in so it's much different when it
comes to apple right it's a it's a large
large large company but the same mindset
applies where he's saying hey look we
don't think that people want to own this
necessarily when they own our stock so
maybe there's some kind of conversion
over time but it makes sense in my
opinion that's why he hasn't done it yet
will that change in the future i think
that's the big question yeah it is very
interesting also that this is all
happening and he's starting to talk
about this more as you see other major
tech companies like facebook etc start
going into these technologies and start
talking about how they're going to
leverage them uh on top of that you get
all the anti-trust pressures and the
judge ruling that uh apple does have to
allow other types of payment services
within their apps in their app store so
there's a lot of kind of complexity in
this analysis in terms of like why would
they be going into this but ultimately i
think what you do is you can you can say
okay where are we now fast forward 10 20
years and this stuff is going to be
pervasive and so of course the
incumbents they have two options either
they're going to embrace the innovative
technology and the superior technology
or they're going to get disrupted and
what literally might happen is those
that embrace it win and continue to uh
to evolve and succeed and those who
choose to ignore it end up actually
failing and so this is a story as well
as time in terms of the innovator's
dilemma are you willing to actually go
and look at the new technology are you
willing to incorporate that new
technology we just saw actually stripe
uh put matt huang from uh paradigm on
their board of directors right a payment
company saying wait a minute hold on
there's a whole new sector that we may
not be experts at but we need to go find
somebody who is an expert somebody who
does spend all day thinking about this
who's very thoughtful and say can you
come join our board of directors and can
you make sure that we do not get
disrupted by this new space and i think
that you know imagine if apple all of a
sudden not only said hey look our ceo
owns this stuff oh maybe we'll go ahead
and integrate some of the technologies
but let's go find a leader in the
industry and let's put them on our board
of directors let's hire them as an uh
advisor let's start to build some sort
of like skunk works type r d um you know
corner of the apple business that is
solely focused on these technologies
like those are all things that an
innovative company would pursue uh we
don't see that yet obviously it sounds
like they're kind of early in their
journey here but to know that the ceo
the most important person at the company
in terms of uh driving strategy and
direction of the business he's into this
stuff i think lends itself that there's
a high likelihood that they could go do
that stuff in the future yeah and i
think i think the thing to think about
too is like it only really takes a few
individuals right that own and operate
these major companies so when you think
about jack dorsey like the impact he has
had on bitcoin has been tremendous not
only from like a kind of put a stake in
the ground and say hey i believe in this
technology as kind of someone who built
multiple companies uh really well but
from his ability to go in and transform
the market right what he's done with
twitter what he's doing with square cash
app etc tim cook has that same ability
if not bigger there's i was just looking
up the numbers 113 million people use
iphones in the united states 50 50 of
smartphone users so when you think about
his ability to really make change
fundament fundamental change uh and
drive this technology forward he has uh
he has a large large large ability to do
that